people of the internet retro Records who
are here just a dad who loves games and
the stories they tell welcome back to
Hogwarts Legacy this is
as I remind you guys at the beginning of
every episode our dark arts playthrough
we did not do that on the first
playthrough we are here I keep hoping is
it finally time to learn one of the
unforgivables is it finally time to
learn crucio
I don't know here's where we're at right
now back on the path Professor fig is in
the map chamber let's go ahead and Mark
that I should speak to him about recent
events
what's going on here Professor magic uh
welcome in good to see you this is
crawling with Victor rookwood's lot and
Ryan Rock's loyalists
working together all right but it is not
a friendly Alliance I'm sure you'll
agree that we need to find a way in
other than the front gate do you want us
to do stealth okay
find a way in other than the front gate
and because we're
yeah can't can't fly on the Broom right
here all right so this is just where we
were
see if those goblins are still out here
where's he at
is he the only one here
revelio dude has changed the way I play
games
we were playing through Star Wars
recently and man I just keep wanting to
cast rebellio
oh yeah let's see what's in this area I
can just do revelio
there are a lot of games that have
features like revelio
but they always it's kind of uh kind of
breaks the immersion a little bit
what
no come on there's no way you knew I was
here
in other games it
fig
nice shot my man
confringo obliterated him
why are you still being quiet fig they
just completely blew our cover right
there
but um as I was saying like in this game
it just totally works it fits perfectly
within the world yes there is a spell
that does exactly that
and it's called revelio
oh Dustin that's a good point they could
have done like force
could have been like a force ability
yeah
where it really drove me crazy is in uh
like The Last of Us
Joel has like this sense which I guess
sort of makes sense because
if you were actually in the room your
hearing would be a little bit more
you you could sense where things were
positioned in the room probably a lot
better than you could with just
headphones but still and then like
Batman
Arkham Arkham Asylum and Arkham Knight
all those games
which even with Batman I feel like did
they did they try to explain it in
Batman because it's supposed to be a
gadget that he's using or something
that's right simply they're both here
bring me the child we wouldn't need the
child if you hadn't sent a dragon to
retrieve the container I spent months in
countless Ministry favors tracking
you let them board The Carriage my
options were limited once I knew it
would be inconveniently beyond my reach
of that infernal School have you not
acquired enough power here
tunnel under my family home
allowed me
you are here only because you are
descended from a keeper and May at some
point inadvertently become valuable we
had an agreement I will share with you
the power that I discovered if you
locate the stores of magic that are yet
to be found
so
unless you want another demonstration of
my power a power that you one day hope
to wield
bring me the child I wish we had stepped
out right here
we could have taken them
fig and and me the main character just
just step out oh that would have been so
epic I'm here with the wandering they're
digging for stores of magic and Ryan
Rock knows about the keepers yes I
caught that too
Professor Rookwood said that you'd
understand more once you complete the
next trial let's get into that castle
can we go back stealth I think we're
good
oh
why does it automatically bring you
outside
pass on to my mum
okay so wait do they know I'm here or
not
dude they're all just dropping in but I
don't think they know
all right
I'm gonna try to do this as much stealth
as that
way no what this is not a stealth
playthrough anyway
not a stealth playthrough
[Music]
Daddy coming back
man there's a lot of people in this area
oh my gosh
thank you
you know what we really need to get is
the transform spell
s
like I can't move without one of them
attacking him somewhere
got another wig and weld might as well
use it
oh it's not ready yet
oh no I see that electricity on the
ground
now you got inferior too
is this every enemy in the game in this
one area
we've got the animagus we've got the
Goblins we've got inferior
you just need some trolls
trolls and spiders
all right sir
oh come on can't reach him
oh he's just Out Of Reach
what
all right wait for him to shoot
oh that is so unfortunate
hello sir
knock you off your little perch up there
you have uncollected rewards okay you've
been that's been on my menu forever
maybe I should finally take a look and
see what it is
all right into our combat section here
The protector's Ensemble claim that
I think we also have this one too Goblin
silver resistance
and I believe that's it
yep there we go
building HP trivia for tonight
what's that about Lindsay I'm curious do
it do explain
revelio
all right looks like there's a lot of
stuff for us to grab in here
Forest rivet gloves
oh wait hold on there's another chest
yeah right there
Cloud Roth welcome in my friend how's it
going
good to see you here
green striped gloves and they are an
upgrade
you'd imagine if we didn't actually go
and sell that gear before we started
this
you'd just be getting the constant
your gear is full your gear is full
so I'm trying to avoid doing the Merlin
puzzles on this playthrough
we may have to do a few of them at some
point but
I'm just really focusing on the story
with this one
all right destruction
see if we missed anything over here I
think this is the way we're
can we open this yet
it's not
all right so we can go over this up the
steps over here wait is it says there's
a
where is this guy the infamous foe
[Music]
Arjun we are on one of the story quests
right now
heading to Rookwood Castle
with our Mentor Professor fig at our
side
got another little item right here
42 I'll take it
I think he's in here the infamous foe
at least I hope so or it could be
glitched or something maybe it only
comes out at night
whoa
fig how did you I think fig just
operated
I suppose that's the quick way down
Okay so we've got one right there one
right there there are more enemies
nearby
all right so let's
activate that one
activate that one that is
that one
I need to find all of them and cost them
quickly in succession
I guess we did miss that Infamous foe oh
well
we'll find it later oh it doesn't you
don't think it spawns while you're doing
the mission gotcha
The Rookwood seller
that makes sense I guess if they don't
want it to
Goblin tracks that attack you when
you're in the middle of a main mission
see where they lead
oh dude this is a big uh
key part of the story here and what's
going on
this must be it the store of that right
there
it looks empty
making all of it why are they still here
Ryan Rock said there's more to be found
and if these ropes are so good man
they're so good we'll be located here
wherever it is we need to find it before
they do
where is that portrait
I bet we go this way Professor fig
Lio
huh that's interesting whenever you see
one of those in the castle
there's like a little secret
bit of loot behind it
I heard something I was hoping that was
you oh there he is
hello Charles
hold on we just want to explore for a
little bit
man the level of detail in this game
is something I will always remember and
cherish
just like all the artwork and the
architecture and
every little oh look at that there's a
phoenix
right there that's cool
got a chest over here
lavender patch scarf
all right Charles we can talk now how's
it going the goblins and dark Wizards he
looks like your grandfather digging the
stools of magic and have broken open
some sort of container no
hey Patrick welcome in you imagined if
as you told Percival a goblin in his
vault was wielding a powerful Magic
then they have somehow learned
it cannot be answer they know you are a
keeper ranrock used the term this makes
no sense how did we shall discuss this
later right now you must complete the
next trial
I deserve to know more surely I've
proven myself
in light of what's happened perhaps you
should tell me everything now the power
you stand to wield must first be fully
understood the trials will in Charles
know knowledge is dangerous indeed
in the wrong hand you're just a portrait
what do you care they have to outwit ran
Rock and my unfortunate namesake very
well Professor tell me where I need to
go I shall reveal the path Professor fig
must leave you now dang
dang fig
he just like he just cast you aside
Professor fig must leave you now
right here
I would join you if you could
I shall await your arrival in the map
chamber sorry fig feels bad man feels
bad
all right the second trial
let us begin
you're hurt Christy what wait what's
this are you what happened
like speaking of architecture and just
the art style
these these trial areas
really look awesome too
I'm doing well Patrick thanks for asking
man
hope you're what is today Thursday hope
your Thursday is going well so far
all right got another right here we can
investigate
oh that's right this one is so cool if
this is the one I'm thinking about the
boss fight at the end
I don't want to give it away if you guys
haven't seen it yet
because it's a really fun one
all right so can I accio you
we can
do I need to use you to get
higher anywhere
oh wow look at that there's already one
in there can I take you through here
I can
okay now we got two
position that not to climb out of it
it's the answer
now you can search the chest
okay now if I go back
yeah there we go
all right so let's see you can bring you
over here
wait is that gonna be
is that gonna be tall enough maybe I
have to levios sew them
oh that one does not levioso
that should be enough right
oh come on you can make that jump
you blew out your hip at work Christy oh
my gosh
I'm so sorry to hear that
yikes
that sounds painful too
go
oh my goodness
moving stairs
yeah yeah this is definitely the one I
was thinking
boss at the end of this is really really
fun
I mean the boss itself it's something
you've seen before but it's just like
the mechanics of the fight are pretty
cool
all right now our first time through we
found all these chests but I don't
really care about those this time
we'll need to move it I'm more just want
to
get to the end
oh that's right we have to let's see
we have to go through first
do we have to hit this first
Wingardium Leviosa
the level design and the lighting writes
yeah I was really impressed with with
this uh
honestly I was kind of disappointed they
didn't explore this concept again
but then again I feel like that's one of
the strengths of the game is they do
such a good job of
of really keeping it to where
you don't get too stuck doing the same
thing except with like side quests but
like the main missions and all of that
I thought they did a great job with
those
keeping it fresh
excuse me sir
I don't know who he just blocked right
there but
investigate the next one here
okay so I think
that sort of thing is repositioning the
old toys in the past oh that's so cool
all right blue flat cap
okay that's where we need to get to
right there
but let's see do we walk through here
first
and then blast you again
yep
wait this is not the way we already no
no this is where we're supposed to go
okay
I hear it
I hear it we're getting closer
there it is
remind you of some places in Assassin's
Creed Valhalla I haven't played that
Assassin's Creed is it pretty good
played a few of it for for there to have
been so many of the Assassin's Creed
games I've only played a few of them
actually
all right so we've got this guy over
here oh
okay
didn't mean to attack you right there
but
you just gotta roll with it now huh
I'm surprised accio does anything to
them it's
they're so big you think they would be
too heavy
oh
he was already destroyed so nothing
happened
oh no yeah see here oh I love this like
they're slowly introducing you to the
mechanic because you're like what the
heck is happening right
then you figure out wait a second he's
in the other dimension
I don't know why he's in the other
dimension but that's where he is
there we go
hey Patrick thank you for the gifted sub
over to Magicka
Magicka congratulations
enjoy your ad-free viewing on the
channel and the emotes
okay so now we've got to move this guy
oh wait I remember this one hold on
and I made it way more difficult than it
needed to be
I do remember that
okay wait and then can we just go
through here
okay wait
can I just do this
that's it right okay yeah the first time
we did that
oh my goodness we made it way too
difficult
Valhalla is great but let's you think
too much or makes you think too much
yeah they're gonna attack Us in here
aren't they
they're going to attack us
wait why do we why did that one go down
instantly
did I upgrade
I don't understand haven't we been doing
that same combo earlier and it hasn't
been taking them down that quickly
you know what I'm not complaining though
let's see what's over here
okay wait hold on though
I not want to explore what's up here
first
Rebellion
ah see like what
I'm pretty sure this is where you're
supposed to go you're supposed to
activate all of these little points here
literally one shot I know dude
the others that was not happening oh I
think this area is just to get that
chest
which honestly I'm not too worried about
we're already full on gear anyway
yeah I'm not gonna worry about that I'm
just gonna go on
especially since we know it's not
anything
not anything special in there
open
Black Flag was your first Platinum I did
enjoy Black Flag did not Beat It
oh yes we're here I remember when I got
to this part I said okay they just gave
us five weekend low potions out of a
chest you know that's gonna mean we got
a boss fight coming all right before we
go in there let's make sure we've
equipped our Max gear
in all possible slots
okay we're good there
I think we do have a better hat
yeah plus four actually
trying out some new layouts for my
spells I had a a setup that I used for
the first playthrough
and have been using something similar
here but we've just tweaked it a little
bit yeah see look at this
as soon as you get in it's like what is
happening right here man
just see swords floating
see if it takes him out
oh it does let's go maybe they're lower
level
or maybe I just I don't know wasn't
paying attention or something
all right so then let's do this
yep one shot
now we go through let's go ahead and hit
you with a ancient Magic
see isn't there another big one there he
is
there he is
oh man was that it
no not so fast
defensive Guardian
oh that's right this one's a little bit
different
oh he does another one
just in time man
these fights are just so cool I love
these Guardian fights
[Music]
so that does a little bit to him just
not much
what do you got for us this time another
purple
so 61 from Expelliarmus
levioso no damage
oh wait did that not damage him because
he wasn't
he wasn't like down on the ground
man I remember the first time we fought
this guy I was losing my mind
yeah you can't really do much damage
until he
goes to one knee
even with even with Stupify it doesn't
really seem to
and he does a little bit
come on
and I also have my Stupify where it
causes the curse so it's it's worth me
worth me hitting that when it pops up
but the office
[Music]
come on go to one knee
what's another one
he's not even that he's almost a half
all right let's hit him with ancient
magic okay yeah it did damage him but it
also sent him to one knee
let's hit him with one more see if we
can sneak one more in there let's go and
we took him down again
174 with Defender right there
oh yeah
I remember this part because I was
saying man there needs to be something
they need to add something different to
this fight because it was too similar to
the previous one
and then
they give him a completely new attack
almost wish it would have been even more
powerful though
although I don't know maybe if you get
hit by that it might do a lot more
damage than I realize
it's just real easy to block it
oh that's awesome
you hit him with glacias when he's in
the middle of swinging it
oh now he goes back to this
whoa
how'd she do it
wow we did both of the dueling Feats as
well
plus 35 XP
programmer now barely got hit do we yeah
I was kind of just like zoned out not
zoned out I guess zoned in
I was totally focused and I played that
fight
already so
I didn't even think about it being hard
mode though yeah it wasn't too bad
honestly so far the CR the I feel like
the most difficult thing with hard mode
is when you get into an area that has
like a big swarm of enemies like just
just a horde of them multiple ones all
around you
and you're constantly getting little
indicators popping up above your head
yeah I wish the boss had been a little
bit more difficult travels
please have a seat another big story
moment coming up chat
this is your first time pay close
attention most Intrigue to here
we're ready
I've something to show you
bothered these are my colleagues from
Hogwarts
father hasn't spoken since my brother
died
very tragic story here on my travels I
confirmed that which I've always been
in a story that oddly mirrors
Sebastian's Quest too
probably intentional I say oddly but
there's almost certainly intentional
what have you done
I took his pain
so clearly Rackham did not have the same
abilities Uncharted magic is Adora
you can only see what has been sealed in
the jar and we do not know what power
that may hold or he never pursued it but
the traces of that magic are different
from what I've seen before
thank you
um I forgot about that part that he you
actually do get some words from him
right there
oh man
all right
yeah Kellen yeah yeah so the day that we
went to
Universal uh most of the other people
had already went the day before that
were there with us but Miranda I met we
met her James expect to go now we met
her at our gameplay session
and she hadn't been
and James had already went he'd already
used his ticket so she and I went and
wrote a bunch of uh Harry Potter rides
there
yeah it was it was a lot of fun though a
lot of fun peace no less
you did the third trial yesterday
Professor Rookwood told me about what
happened at Rookwood Castle
in light of the dire circumstances in
which we find ourselves it is most
fortunate that someone so competent is
following this path thank you Professor
I shall keep the second artifact come to
Ziva right now good are you ready more
has them tricked
what was the glowing strand that Isadora
pulled from her father's chest it was
pain you will understand more about her
akrums as you complete the trials
if you level up before progressing too
much on hard mode some of the fights are
fairly easy the more you progress yeah
especially with like I feel like
I should have done my first play through
hard mode when I didn't learn any
unforgivables
because the I mean dark arts man they're
so powerful in this game it comes next
in this case introductions are in order
so I almost think that's gonna offset me
bumping up to Hard Mode anyway mistress
Nev Fitzgerald
I must say that I was not entirely
surprised to learn that a student had
been completing the trials
I've always believed Hogwarts students
capable of anything they set their minds
to thank you Professor it's a pleasure
to meet you as well I am certain that
you are more than capable of completing
my trial however I must first how
emotionally say prepare the location of
your next trial what you're just a
portrait what can you do Professor Vince
Gerald
manage the inconvenience of
well
a vainglorious and exasperating
Headmaster
indeed I should
I shall confirm that everything is in
order immediately that's right I do
remember now I do remember what she
asked Professor Fitzgerald needs some
time to clear the way forward until then
you should continue to hone your magic
if you learn more about ran Rock and
Victor rookwood's activities in the
meantime please let us know very well
professor
Cloud Roth yeah that'd be an interesting
idea without would that even be possible
though
Cloud Roth in the chat you guys said if
they made like a hardcore mode with no
indicators
I just don't even know how you would how
you would attempt that
that's what it threw me off a little bit
jumping into Star Wars because there are
no indicators but you have to look at
oh man I guess you would just have to
you'd have to have some sort of red
flash though they'd have to do something
to let you know when you couldn't Parry
an attack I know I know continue to hone
my magic you do learn quickly hopefully
you will soon hear from lodgok as well
and we shall learn how he fared with the
helmet you retrieved well done today as
always we shall speak again soon
oh and Anna I do remember seeing your
comment about the we have not learned oh
it's winter let's go
we have not learned crucio yet
It's gotta be coming soon It's gotta be
I feel like everything else is totally
set up and ready
time for that
[Music]
all right winter is my favorite season
what about you guys what what's your
favorite season from
Hogwarts Legacy
I just love like I love winter in in
real life something about the snow just
the the sight of everything covered in
snow I always love snow levels in games
too
all right see do we have any new mail
nothing new
right what's showing up on our Quest
page right now
yes
finally you guys I knew I knew we had to
be getting close in the shadow of the
study Sebastian wants to meet outside
the Slytherin common room to talk to me
about Slytherin scriptorium meet
Sebastian outside the Slytherin common
room
yes
let's go
it is time you guys it is finally time
to learn our first unforgivable spell
we're definitely gonna need to
figure out a breakdown of how we're
gonna do this I think I'm probably gonna
put it
because there's three unforgivables
total
I think I'm probably gonna put it right
here
or do I want to have all the
unforgivables on one slot
oh man it's tough
because I like having one of each color
although wait they can break any Shield
can't they
oh see they're just so powerful I
received your owl what happened with
ominous I told him none of us
forever
Slytherin and the dark arts the best
prepared will be unfortunately only a
gaunts knows the location of the
scriptorium's entrance and ominous won't
tell me hmm
perhaps I should have a chat with
ominous you
I suppose it's worth a try but don't get
your hopes up you this is annoyingly
stubborn
nothing new I know where he is I'll lead
you to him and then leave you to it come
on
all right this right here this
conversation that that we have with
ominous right here
it is a conversation that going back and
watching it again like when I was making
the video on Sebastian although that
hasn't stopped us before
strictly speaking it has we work on it
I'll let him finish Poltergeist such a
nuisance
this conversation really rubs me the
wrong way and I hate that you don't get
more of a a choice in it I mean
obviously they have to have it where
ominous gets convinced to do it but dude
the way the main character manipulates
good luck ominous I mean just just total
manipulation in this scene
while posing is like oh I'm I'm your
caring friend
like we're we're stooping to Sebastian
levels here with this
do you have a moment watch it watch it
again
it's about to now
ominous
I can find it in you before about what
happened with the undercroft Sebastian
simply wanted me to have a safe place
to try and catch up to the other fifth
years sorry
suppose that makes sense
it's just Sebastian's been pestering me
lately about something and I'm
frustrated with him don't tell me he's
still going on about what was it a
scriptorium he told you about that see
that line right there we were talking
about our house founder and he mentioned
it wouldn't say much more though yes
well he seems to think it contains the
answer to saving Anne I think it's
likely full of dark magic that is better
left untouched we're just casually
mentioning right of course not
I only know about it because of my
favorite aunt noctua
like I do didn't agree with the family
on the use of dark magic we already knew
about his history
there was more to Salazar Slytherin than
worshiping pure blood status
cryptorium and thought its contents
might shed some light on him
she even found the secret entrance in
this very Corridor she wrote regularly
to my father about her efforts to gain
access and then she simply vanished
no one else ever tried to enter
so see we've already like sown that seed
of you've never looked inside
and now I'm pretty sure on my first
playthrough I'm pretty sure I said I
understand your caution but we still
like he doesn't say exactly that he he
twists it another way
to keep manipulating him into agreeing
to this so we're playing we're playing
Lord retro Mort on this playthrough so
we're gonna go all on the manipulation
here I'm sorry about your aunt oh look
at that I'm sorry you want to find out
what happened to her don't you went down
this path with good intentions and lost
her life right Anna I don't know what
the same to happen again you don't know
that history will repeat itself
besides you said you aren't thought like
you
this could honor her memory get you
answers about Slytherin and Sebastian
answers for Anne
your aunt pursued this alone
we could do it together
um
I see what you've done I see what you've
done I confess you've convinced me
I didn't think it possible very well I
shall tell you what I know at least he
like seems aware of it
he's like I know what you just did I
hope I we don't regret this Sebastian
over there where'd he go
these braziers Grant access to the
scriptorium Sebastian you wouldn't tell
me when I practically
it wasn't you who told me
opening the entrance has summoned two
degrees
well three heads are better than one
open it's two heads are better than one
and by that logic three is better than
two didn't like how they did yeah I
agree Magica I agree
that's one of my biggest wait is it are
there four or did I just do it too soon
three brazias are involved
occasionally
yeah we totally did that
oh we're ready
we are ready it is finally time
for Lord retro Mort to begin his true
descent
into dark magic all right we have
noctuagant's first letter here
so this is ominous's Aunt she was going
to find this scriptorium
hoping that she could find something to
prove that Salazar wasn't all about dark
magic and pure blood status
fortunately
we don't really have any evidence for
our boy Salazar painting him in a good
light at least not from this game I must
prove my point we do not need to use the
dark arts as my family instructs when I
reach the scriptorium I will find
evidence that there's more to salsar
Slytherin than we realize
I've written to my brother he now knows
how I access the corridors entrance and
that there's no straight path to reach
the scriptorium it's a maze with many
challenges to solve I hope that my
brother will follow my lead and we can
study our ancestors Legacy together
signed by noctua gold
s ominous your family was here yeah he
knows
she was my aunt
he knows that
didn't tell me
hominess
the journal mentions many challenges
ahead
can we repair all this that's why I said
this could be dangerous aren't nocturnal
kept my father informed until the person
facing a snake
that must be the voice I hear
okay second playthrough I want to ask
you guys about this The Voice he hears
the voice is ancient
Sinister is that the Basilisk
I mean is it the Basilisk or is it just
something set up with this scriptorium
I'm so curious about that
because it all I mean it makes it sound
like it's an ancient voice sinister
and we know the Basilisk is here it's
just like waiting for the air of
Slytherin which
our boy ominous right here
a true heir of Slytherin pure blood
wizard right here
so if if he had wanted to awaken it he
definitely could have see that's the
thing I think it's like in a slumber so
I don't see how it could be
the actual basilisk
they are close to the chamber you think
it's just part of the room Craig yeah
see that's kind of where I ended up on
it
but the fact that he says like it's an
ancient voice sinister
I mean who knows Slytherin was an
incredibly powerful wizard so
you could have definitely set it up it
started when you repaired that relief
to me I'm a parcel mouth
I can hear and speak forget more about
it right here nearly all known parcel
mouths are descended from Salazar
Slytherin I wish all slytherins could
talk to snakes you might not want the
ability to speak past the tongue
it's often associated with dark Wizards
I haven't spoken it in ages but I'd
wager if I speak it now the door will
open I'm hoping you're having second
thoughts
okay now that that's a good point Dustin
it could be
because Salazar of course could speak
Paris tongue as well maybe it's actually
his voice
in some sort of spell that he's left
behind that that to me makes sense I
could see that
no reason we should stop now
it's ironic when I left home I vowed to
leave the dark Hearts behind and yet
here I am
stand back
you just did this one Muriel nice
head it worked ominous you possess a
rabbit look at that man
between the two of you I'm starting to
feel left out such a cool animation
I
never mind clearly inspired by the
chamber Secrets movie there's no clear
Way Forward
like a maze
Salazar Slytherin most likely wanted
this to be difficult to solve
D
and there's more than one gate ahead
then look closely at each gate for Clues
Rebellion
oh my goodness lumos lights up like
crazy down here
and I'm pretty sure we can do this
give us a little bit of light
yeah when the door closed it lit up
oh here's her second letter
Salazar Slytherin buried the scriptorium
deep within Hogwarts I'm afraid I shall
lose my way around these dark corridors
I am a descendant and yet I feel
unwelcome lighting these braziers in the
corridor is helping I shant lose heart
challenge by challenge I will make my
way through
it mentions getting lost and being
unwelcome
nope sorry
okay right here we're gonna need the
let's see what should we call this one
like Moon
and snake with the eye on the right
the dollar requires
focused
oh no there it is
right there
matching the symbols did open it
was about to do that myself
you've got to it first I'm sure you were
Sebastian
next letter set number three yep
I failed the dial and it struck my face
as if it were a real serpent but I must
find a way forward for my family's sake
we should not require children to
conform to old traditions this
scriptorium must have proof that there's
more to our Legacy than meets the eye
ominous
your aunt wanted to change your family's
traditions
she did and she was my favorite person
in the world I should have looked at the
same other symbol that we need
okay so we got that one
all right so it's
one isn't there one in here too
okay yeah we need to open that one I'm
pretty sure it goes with this one right
here so it's it's like the bull and the
Z
I love the game all right that's the C
right there
and that's the bowl there we go look in
the mirror Sebastian the snake's
actually scared you I know I didn't
expect that either the first time I
failed one nice work
because I had not yet read that letter
that said they'll they'll attack if you
get it wrong
all right this should be number four
extraordinary this journey is painful
but rewarding I shall soon find the
scriptorium and discover Untold Secrets
regarding our house founder Salazar
Slytherin intended more than what we've
become I know it no true reference is
painful and arduous challenges but also
Rewards
painful that's the problem no great
here we are again
and of course not an upgrade
keep going all right so we have
let's see what is that bottom one
what do we call that circle with you
know what it looks like it looks like a
patapon
did you guys ever play that game on
PlayStation
pad upon what a good game all right so
we got the patapon or I don't know duck
duck facing to the right might be better
and then is that like the m one kind of
like an m
okay duck facing right
an m
it's a great game if you guys haven't
played it another great game not the
welcoming
okay that one right there
we go
excellent can you cast crucio on
yourself I don't think so
like you can have Sebastian do it
so you can choose to not learn it
which then he'll cast it on you
or you can choose to learn it cast it on
him or you can choose to learn it and
still have him cast it on you I think we
cannot stop now
oh here we go
this is it
oh the music
I think we're locked in
there should be one more note from now
who has not yet finished with us
there it is
the final note
with the scream timed just as we pick it
up I've lost hope I'm locked in I heard
a scream and saw the tortured faces The
Only Way Forward is with an unforgivable
curse
even if I wanted to cast it I have no
one upon whom to do so Salazar Slytherin
created a malicious challenge indeed and
my last correspondence to my brother I'd
invited him here now if he looks for me
alone I'll have led him to his death
despite our differences I wish him no
ill I wish we had parted on better terms
not to have gone ominous
a skeleton
and not to his last country
she mentions being trapped here blocked
by an unforgivable curse
this
is where she died
this is where we'll die I shouldn't have
listened to either of you
ominous I'm truly sorry about your aunt
no no patapon we've had upon fans in the
chat
you said you know what to do tortured
faces on the door and cruise shows I
mean it is kind of obvious main
character I guess is if we cast The
cruciata's Curse it is pretty obvious
that's why notchua died she had no one
to cast the curse on
ominous has the most experience with
this he should cast it you seem to be an
ominous favor will you ask him about
this
I'd rather you ask and better than I do
very well
wish me luck you do it Seb wish we had
some liquid luck
ominous I know this is the last thing
you want to show him what a terrible
friend you are
telemominus it wouldn't be an innocent
victim
we have to open the door
the spell won't work unless you mean it
that's true of all unforgivables if it
must be done then one of you must cast
it
teach me Seb
teach me your dark ways what do we do
now ominous is not going to cast The
cruciatus Curse again ridiculous as if
dying in here is a better option than
causing a damn spell
it's up to us
I can teach you crucial
or I can cast it on yet you didn't see
let's go because I'm not sure I do
ominous knows that yet he's left us no
choice
I don't you answer following not to a
gaunts footsteps I think I can cast this
if I have to
all right this is the part chat if you
guys haven't played it yet if you
haven't made it to this point this is
the key moment you want to be very
specific about make sure you read each
of these very well I don't want to learn
the cruciatus curse I want to learn the
cruciatus curse but you must cast it on
me
teach me the curse and I'll cast it on
you uh yeah Lord retro Mort let's go and
I think it's best if I cast it on you
very well see no like are you sure
so read that very carefully declare
crucio hold on
oh my goodness here we go ladies and
gentlemen
our first unforgivable spell on this
playthrough
the torture curse crucio
about to cast it on our boy Sebastian
here oh dude he looks terrified
thank you
he looked terrified in that moment the
main character
and the scriptorium
I would have done anything to make it
stop
you asked for it
let's keep moving he does he does he's
just gonna shake it off we found
all right I'm putting it right here
Auditorium ominous get in there I can't
believe we're here
this was a cool room man this was so
cool I wish we had had this for all the
founders
I really wish we had had something like
this for each of the founders like a
special area
Salazar Slytherin scriptorium a secret
and well protected room beneath Hogwarts
where Salazar Slytherin appears to have
spent time making various long-term
plans with respect to the student
population and reflecting on
disagreements he had with the other
founders
and then we also have slytherin's spell
book right here
get a good look at that on the outside
ominous
there's a book just that right there man
I found something
you two go ahead let me know what looks
like they're moving around a bit
lumos
I wish it was a bigger area
would like even more to explore
oh man you know it's gonna be right I
knew it
I knew it
Let's uh get rid of a scarf here
actually let's get rid of two of these
can I cast that right here
oh come on
yes Craig it definitely needs a photo
mode
wish your punishment for taking crucio
there was more than one
minus one Wicked weld
right Seb didn't even need a wig and
weld he was all good
oh that's right there's a note here
all right so this is actually written by
Slytherin here dude see imagine if we'd
gottens for all the founders oh would
have been so cool
all right Salazar says I fear we shall
never come to an accord I cannot
persuade even one of them to listen to
reason I had dared hope that godric's
thoughts were aligned with my own it's
interesting that he thinks like
like Gryffindor is the one he felt like
he had the best chance with
that he understood why the caliber of
student needed to be exceptional but he
has fallen prey to the ridiculous notion
that muggleborns are somehow as capable
as purebloods he was Furious when I
expressed my displeasure at his thoughts
on the matter thoughts he had not yet
put voice to I Tire of the Discord and
can no longer bear witness to the
corridors full of inept children
masquerading as witches and wizards uh
yikes it is with heavy heart that I now
know I must go from here and then here
we get oh
this this paragraph right here man
I shall place the creature into a deep
sleep in its chamber until it can be
awakened by one who shares My Views a
descendant willing to reverse the damage
that the others have so carelessly
wrought one who shall rid the school of
those Unworthy of Hogwarts that would
serve only to stain my legacy
yikes dude yikes
oh man
I did not even notice that the first
time
is that
no way is that like the skeleton of
no not a
dude do you think that's a house elf
[Music]
oh my gosh and then I didn't even notice
that the first time
snake right there
someone seems a little bitter
oh there's another one over here
oh man
that just oh it would have been so cool
to get this for the other Founders
something similar hey that just looks
like our uh desk in the room of
requirement all right Sebastian what do
you think looks like a spell book of
some kind
this is incredible Hogwarts found his
possession
what an honor still can't believe
ominous never told me about his arms and
what she found what will you do with
slytherin's spell book what I do with
every book read it
having professed as parents ingrained
that habit early on and so I can do that
later for now I say we explore this room
he takes one step closer it's
breathtaking
it is breathtaking I'll give you that
I don't want to leave but I owe you both
of you without both of you we never have
made it this far
we were lucky we could have died we must
swear never to do this again
come on omis
all right back into the Slytherin
dungeon we go
first Unforgivable
complete
I see a way out
right do you think you guys think that's
what it was a household skeleton not one
but two
oh now Seb puts on the charm now he puts
on the show what I said before we swear
right now never to engage in anything to
do with dark magic again
understood
truly sorry about you understood
doesn't sound like a promise to me it
was after all this I am grateful to know
what happened to her
thank you
does not sound like a promise to me Chad
all right first Unforgivable crucio
casted in the school
I wondered how they were gonna handle
that
all right see it's my first time
learning one I have no idea okay quests
what do we have next fire and vice
let's go man two of the best quests in
the game back to back in the same stream
High Wing's fine I'm keeping an eye on
her she's safe Poppy I promise good
whatever the poachers are up to I want
hiring far from it you said yes and that
some of it had to do with me it did I
overheard them talking in the hog's head
and
sight does this have anything to do with
Rookwood and Harlow coming for you in
the three broomsticks no attack it does
somewhat uh come on dude I'm more
concerned about it give us up that these
Hoagies are up to fair enough
but I hope you'll let me know if I can
be of help especially after what you did
for high Wing does the name horntow Hall
mean anything to you I'm afraid not
why what is it the poacher's best kept
secret apparently
the name came up twice but they never
went into detail I also overheard one of
them bragging about all the gold they're
making at the expense of innocent
creatures undoubtedly the poachers spoke
of this area and I thought if we
searched around a bit it might give us
Clues as to what they're doing if you
ever meet my gran this trip never
happened
I can't believe they set that up and
then you never meet the grand
if you ever meet my crayon this trip
never happened I thought that was like
a little nod to something that was going
to happen later
keeping things from ground hallway I
know I know everything
thank my best friend after highway but
she swapped outages
will do something
ill-advised whatever gave her that idea
right what gave her that idea I'll say
this about Poppy
I think she's got potential in the dark
Army that we will form
I think she does
or I should say the Dark Army Lord retro
Mort will be forming Sebastian
maybe our right hand man but poppy could
very easily overtake that spot natsai I
don't know I don't think that's I would
would join us Poppy I feel like she
might come over to the dark side with us
I do
an entire Castle to Rome yet you choose
to wander here yeah what's it to you we
don't want any trouble we're simply
passing through
do you take Us For Fools it's one of the
new spell dudes you don't want to see it
either hiding around here I can't say it
right now with the poachers
we aren't involved with them if anything
we want Molly let's dehydrate I hope for
your sake that is true Our Kind is
swiftly losing patience with the
poachers and those they work with
DLC with Gran Maybe
I definitely felt like it was setting up
something like we were gonna meet her
later in the game
and then it never happened Centos aren't
exactly fans of wizard kind and the
poachers aren't helping matters
but why would he think that we had
anything to do with poachers I wonder if
he could say notice the poachers talking
with a few Villages get away from here
you need to run stag perhaps that's why
the centaurs are suspicious
oh is that true but Poppy the only one
who doesn't react to the unforgivables
no way
come on can we save you go
run run away
imagine if you actually could
beautiful
come on no
we tried
you're straying too far away she's right
here
it seems that a lot of beasts have been
more aggressive than usual lately
J.A Kobe welcome in thank you for the
follow
what
poppy walk with me please
go
I have to say like the way the NPC or
the way the companions move and stuff
like it really is most the time it's
very
uh what's the word like user friendly
like they don't lag behind
if you run they'll run
this is
odd all right investigating not entirely
sure look around save the game
yeah yeah you can find out why trying to
save the animal but poachers nah crucio
you got me
Jacoby
all right regroup regroup let's see
let's see we only got five minutes left
we were that close to being done Jacoby
you just managed to sneak that in there
yeah yeah still counting we got five
minutes left
wouldn't they indeed
this part was so epic
I'm going along
no no gear slot's full again
is Goblin metal
seems out of place in a poacher camp
I should tell poppy about it I don't
really care about the
pelt
poor beasts whatever gear is in there
I'm just gonna be really quiet for the
next five minutes
feeling about this
I mean did any of you guys see something
like this coming
oh wait she wants to go this oh that's
right we go this way first
the the tent was the part I'm talking
about
I just did not expect that definitely
poachers my jaw dropped that's what they
do
a closer look that was one of the
sections
poppy should we
hard to say from up here
let's get a better Laser Land
all right she's done uh this was one of
the areas we got to play early
and my jaw just dropped when we opened
that tent
you saw it on the preview Anna yeah I
I just could not believe
what a great idea for for a uh
I know you like like a concept like
remembering that from Harry Potter and
the Goblet of Fire
the the whole deal with the Weasley tent
whoa
that happened to me too
because see at that point we didn't know
we didn't know that you're basically
gonna just like take out a ton of
wizards in this game
I was thinking you might actually be
able to at that point when we first
played this I was still thinking oh you
can do like a full
pacifist run right like where you only
disarm enemies but see watch even when
you do petrificus they just kind of like
fade away like that
show yourself
all right I'm gonna show myself ready
here I am
watch this the bridge
I love that
my first two times doing this
I never destroyed the bridge so I had no
idea that you could repair oh it
murder murder I know
so when I said I said to the guy who was
helping me we all had kind of someone
there sort of walking us through the
game
and so when I walked up to that first
guy over there and hit him with
petrificus I was like oh oh no he just
fell off and I was telling him I said I
thought I was trying to
or uh what did I say to him I said I was
trying to do a run without hurting
anybody you know I don't want to kill
anybody
and he got the weirdest look on his face
he was just kind of like uh
you just had this grin
this grin of just like oh I'm so sorry
because that is not gonna be possible is
what he wanted to say
so no never
no dead
even think about that
oh yeah if you could have used the
unforgivables in the preview
which at that point had they showed off
had they showed off the dark arts battle
arena
I can't remember I think they had right
I'll see I think there's a couple more
things for us to explore around here
full don't even care at this point
I am here for the gold though
I will happily accept the galleons all
right here we go man
this right here
epic moment epic moment
into the poacher tent we go
just in time
it's in time for us to use crucio again
definitely going to be needed in this
area
which I played this whole first part
stealth I want to see what happens if
you just start running through there if
more of them show up
rocking fighting ring
how could they possibly enjoy this the
centers have every right to be disgusted
with wizard kind there must be more
dragons here the poachers are far too
greedy to run a fighting ring with only
two dragons
we should take advantage of most guys
being in fight and look around
be discreet you especially can't afford
to be spotted
all right
we are a family-friendly stream by the
way guys we have that little Channel
redemption in there as more of a joke
than anything
you got sport what what wait wait what
did you get spoiled Marielle watch this
watch this
hello sir
window
[Applause]
means you can't use curses
look at the chat twisting
twisting our words you guys
come around to our way of thinking where
they join us
poppy over here casting for pindo
yes they would have my own
vegetable
s
who was that Dustin with the tin
makes it better LOL
oh man
I should have I should have seen that
coming I really should we're a
family-friendly stream guys so I put
that one in there as a joke I was like
oh this would be funny we never curse on
stream anyway
it's like this would be really cool if
we put that in as a as a channel Point
Redemption now you guys trying to turn
it on me like that look at that
we're doing our our evil playthrough
Lord retro more we just learned our
first ever Unforgivable
and then you guys gonna try to say no
cursing
as in no in-game cursing
did you hear
me totally using cursio in here by the
way
we've been waiting for this moment oh
wait something's going on behind you
what's going on down there I mean you
have a timer for this one see we didn't
even start a timer you can't do it
do we need to stay
spandex
I don't know
grossio
oh I hit the wrong button no
oh my gosh they're like actually doing a
lot of damage right now
flippindo come on poppy get in there
do we just cast it in midair what the
heck
who do we cast that on right there
I couldn't hear what that donation was
the music was so loud
I have to go back and read it
is that it is that it for now
here's the animagus
[Applause]
all right dude we're doing terrible with
the Perrys right now
absolutely terrible
here we go get some incendio going all
right now let's start
start getting the Parry down there's
just so many enemies
they're almost always going to be
somebody attacking like that right there
there it is
are you serious right now
oh he was already cursed I probably
shouldn't have even bothered
there we go finally get rid of that
animagus
all right get rid of the Executioner
transform you
into a chicken
come on it can't hit him in there there
we go
and then you up here
has anybody tried if you just mess
around will more actually show up
I wonder if they'll if they will
actually show up yeah we're on hard mode
may have been a bad idea
this part was just Epic
oh I need to go I need to pull up uh
I couldn't hear the donation of the
music
well goodbye to that gentlemen
Poppy's grin
at the dragon who just ate a human and
then
incinerated some others
her look of awe and wonder
and There She Goes
[Music]
that was heberdeen black I'm guessing
the egg we have belongs to that dragon
foreign
she
wouldn't have left without it what now
she didn't exactly leave us a calling
card I I don't know oh it's right I
forgot about the things
the goblins and definitely not the
fighting ring the last thing I planned
on was a dragon egg and the poacher saw
us which cannot be good
let's get out of here myself standing
here let's get to safety we can sort
this out later you're right it
their prey and and right now we're it
indeed be careful won't you I shall see
you back at the castle